instantly recognizable from the sky a
closer look reveals that Paris is a
changed City vehicles are scarce on
roads usually snarled with traffic
neighborhoods once-vibrant
are nearly deserted as days passed
people are forced to adapt to the French
president's order to stay indoors to
stem the spread of the coronavirus a
reduced French Parliament discussed the
crisis lesson 30 MPs were allowed to sit
in accordance with new rules
irrespective of our personal
responsibilities or our convictions
there are times can diverge we stand by
the idea here that it is in all our
interest and out of the country to
guarantee continue to serve our citizens
during the confinement people may leave
home for essential work to buy medicines
or food at a market in a Paris suburb
some shoppers ventured out at a bakery
people kept their distance I know we are
not allowed to get out vert each is a
SAP to be able to go to the local bakery
barrels are being held behind closed
doors with only close relatives allowed
thousands of police officers have been
deployed to enforce the regulations
those breaking them are find across
France it is a similar picture locked up
cities boats moored in picturesque
harbors in the west of the rural town of
Chalet is shuttered and quiet the Sports
Centre closed only the supermarket open
well this is a pretty typical small town
in regional France and on a day like
this with fine weather normally the cafe
behind me on the main square would be
packed with people enjoying the sunshine
but it is empty the streets are empty
there are very very few cars and I have
to say it is very eerie life under
lockdown is clearly challenging but as
coronavirus cases in France rapidly
climb opinion poll suggests that most
people support the restrictions and in
such an unusual time there are displays
of solidarity that ease the tension each
night in France's cities towns and
villages Cheers ring out to thank the
health workers and
battle tirelessly to save lives Natasha
Butler al Jazeera western France